this is from fox that says james madison
university is under fire for pushing
controversial rhetoric as part of its
freshman orientation training for
student leaders
the powerpoint presentation and
accompanying video addressed topics like
social justice identity power and
privilege
and labeled any person who fits the
parameters of white male straight and
christian as oppressors in a detailed
chart
jmu college republicans chairwoman
juliana mcgrath
shared her frustration with fox news
saying the training at the virginia
university that's meant to bring
students together will ultimately be
divisive
she said quote when you're teaching
about things like this the goal is to
try to bring people together and try to
get people to understand different life
experiences but by saying because you're
white you're an oppressor because you're
straight you're an oppressor because
you're a male you're an oppressor that
actually brings people farther apart and
it doesn't actually accomplish any of
the goals of what i feel like they were
trying to do
according to mcgrath the most shocking
inclusion in the presentation was the
implication that followers of the
christian faith specifically were deemed
as oppressors even though all religious
individuals regardless of denomination
believe in the same thing a higher power
she said quote in our chapter of college
republicans we actually have a very
diverse chapter and we have people of
different races of different backgrounds
and specifically of different religious
beliefs and that's always been very
welcome i feel like no matter your
political beliefs you always find some
type of common ground i think sometimes
religion is the common ground so and so
forth okay
uh
a lot of this unfortunately is
unremarkable because we've these this is
the kind of re-education
that we see in colleges across the
country
uh most
universities at this point this is their
primary function
this is a
feature not a bug
it's not like you send your kids to
college and then they just so happen to
be
brainwashed into leftist dogma that's
why the universities exist at this point
that is their primary goal
so that makes this unremarkable but
but still important
but i'm really
i really zero in on what she said here
um
juliana mcgrath
she said the goal is to try to bring
people together and try to get people to
understand different life experiences
but when you do all of this you're
you're you're tearing people apart
and that doesn't accomplish any of the
goals that you're that you're trying to
accomplish she said
well no juliana let me explain this to
you it is important that you understand
i don't be accused of mansplaining here
okay i don't need that on top of all the
other crimes i've committed
maybe that'll be next maybe christy
gnome
tomorrow will tweet about how i
mansplained
she'll at this point just dye your hair
pink
cut it down
call me a mansplainer why not
go full feminist anyway
it is important to explain this uh to
anyone who doesn't understand it i think
there are a lot of people on the right
who still don't understand this
um
no
these these these kind of indoctrination
seminars
where they're saying that white people
and males and christians are oppressors
and evil and all that
this is not a misguided but
well-intentioned attempt
to bring people together and to make
people understand each other's life
experiences no
this is not something that's clumsy and
we'll say well they're they're trying to
accomplish something they're just not
accomplishing it
they just so happen to be doing the
opposite of what they're trying trying
to accomplish no they are accomplishing
their goal 100
the goal is not to bring anyone together
that is not the goal
the division the hostility the suspicion
that's engendered by these sorts of
programs that is the point that's why
they're doing it
there is nothing well intentioned about
this at all
they are trying to drive that wedge in
between you in between all of us
and not one wedge but a million wedges
dividing people into a million different
categories and subcategories
even one single individual person is now
divided in is is chopped into into a
thousand different pieces and put into
different compartments and different
labels and everything everybody's
warring against each other
that is
totally the point it's why they're doing
it
so when you say they're not achieving
what they want to achieve yes they are
they are doing a great job of
accomplishing their goals
they want to divide the american
population
uh they
to to inflame
tribalism that's part of the point here
and also
to to tear down
our history
and all of the authorities of the past
you know to separate us from our own
history
we western civilization
is informed
shaped by christian values by the
christian religion
and that's why that's one of the main
reasons why they hate it
and that's why if you notice they focus
on christianity
much more than they focus on something
like islam
because they are trying to destroy
eat away at chop down the foundations of
western civilization
that that is the point
they want us to live fully immersed
in modernity
severed from all of the ties of the past
hating everybody that came before us
our ancestors all of the people who
built this civilization that we now live
in want us to hate all of them and hate
all that hate our past
hate anybody connected with our past
they want to identify the villains of
the past
in a very simplistic way well if you're
a white if you're a christian if you're
a male those are all the villains of the
past
any any of the your historical heroes
who you thought were heroes well if
they're they were white male whatever
and they weren't heroes they were they
were oppressors
and their progeny to this day still
oppressors
[Music]
that is
again the whole entire point
and it is
crucially important for us to understand
that
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated